مسلسل التلفزيون الواقع دبي بلينج اللي
هذه الايام محور حديث الناس وعامل جذر
كبير بدا عرضه في 27 اكتوبر وبحسبنا فليكس
حصل المسلسل على 130000 ساعه مشاهده خلال
الاسبوع الماضي وكان من ضمن قائمه الاكثر
مشاهده كمان المسلسل فكره بالكم على
مشاركه انه كده 10 من اصحاب الملايين سواء
في مجال العقار او الاعلام او مواقع
التواصل او البزنس الفرصه للمشاهدين
للمشاهده كواليس حياته والتعرف على تفاصيل
ما وراء الستار المخملي اللي بيغطي حياته
عمل الخارجيه وهذا الشيء طلع فيكي الكثير
من الدراما والخناقات والنماذج وغيرها من
الامور
[موسيقى]
المسلسل بدا عرض وبدات الفعل المتابعين
والمختلفه في ناس شافت في نوع من الافعال
السطحيه والطرف وتشويه لسوره دبي المراه
لكن كمان في نفس الوقت في ناس حبه العمل
وكانت انه يا جماعه لا تحمل العمل فوق ما
يحتمل هو مجرد مسلسل ترفيهي احنا معانا
اليوم نورتنا في استوديو عندكم اعلاميه
لجين عمران احدى بطلات مسلسل التلفزيون
المسلسل
يعطيك العافيه الله يعافيك اول شيء يعني
ايش اللي خلاك تدخلي هذا المجال اصلا كنت
متردده اكثر من مره بس بعدين لما جلست مع
او شو كان شركه المنتجه بس لما جلس بعدين
شفت ثقتهم لطفهم همم رغبتهم الجديديه وهمم
يعني يكون معاهم موجوده بالبرنامج
قلت ليش لا الفكره اصلا كانت موجوده سابقا
واحنا عملنا حلقه بايلوت لصالح قناه ام بي
سي بس صارت ظروف وشقه الظروف انه نحنا ما
نعرض الحلقه الفايبرت ولا نكمل في المشروع
فلم عن حياه لجين نفسه صحيح انا حياتي انا
والعائله والاصدقاء وكان فيها رسائل كثير
رائعه جدا يعني لو حتى عرضت الان الحلقه
ما هي همم مربوطه لا بزمن ولا مربوطه
باحداث معينه او مكان معين همم فلم العرض
عليه مره ثانيه شفت نتفليكس همم
منصه انترناشونال هتوصلني لا لفل مختلف لا
مشاهدين مختلفين فقلت هذه فرصه بالنسبه لي
لسه في جزء بالعالم الغربي ساره ما يعرفوا
الصوره الحقيقيه للمراه العربيه بشكل عام
والمراه السعوديه بشكل خاص لسه شايفين هي
مقموعه ما لها صوت مسموع غير مثقفه ما لها
راي والى اخره
لا يمكن تعتمد على نفسها فانا حاولت انه
من خلال مشاركه هذه ابين الصوره الصح
المغلوطه عند الغرب ده والحمد لله النتيجه
كانت مذهله بالنسبه لي ومرضيه ومثل ما
تمنيت بس ايش رايك في الكلام اذا اللي
بيتقال بما انك ذكرتي هذه النقطه انه لا
المسلسل طلع صوره مشوهه للمراه اللي
بتعتمد على زوجها اللي
تخليت عن زميلاتك في العمل ابدا انا ما
تخليت على احد صار مسؤول عن نفسه اوكي
وبعدين همم
مثل حياتنا حياتنا هتشوف فعلا المراه
المعتمده على زوجها المراه المعتمده على
نفسها المراه المستقله المراه
المسلسل الموجوده هل انت بتشوفيها ولا
فيها هل هذه النماذج موجوده ولا هي مبالغه
هي موجوده موجوده
الحقيقي وموجود المزيف وموجود الزين
وموجود الشين بس احنا للاسف يعني لما يطلع
برنامج همم ريالتي لازم الكلبر اذا كان
الكلب رايح فتح يقول لك متصنعيني يا اخي
طيب ما فهمنا لكم يعني بس هذا الواقعنا في
كل الالوان هل كان في سكربت او مثلا
اعطوكم الكلام اللي ينقال او القصص اللي
راح تصير ابدا هذا اللي صار كله تصرفات
طبيعيه يعني تصرفات ذاتيه من كل شخص حسب
طبيعه حسب شخصيته همم وهذه الاولى اكيد لك
مليون بالميه عني انا الناس اليوم ساره
انت تعرفيني من زمان من خلال السوشال
ميديا او صداقتنا شفتي شيء مختلف عن
شخصيتي بالواقع همم بالمسلسل او البرنامج
لا هو انت طلعت الملاك بينهم بالعكس هو
انت طلعتي اكثر وحده يعني
اكثر شيء سويتيني
اكثر
على فكره بعضهم بعد التصوير يكلموني
يكلموني ترى كذا كذا
بعطيهم ارشادات اذا حبه بس همم في النهايه
انا بالنسبه لي علي من شخصيتي علي من دوري
انا ماني مسؤول عن الاخرين اوكي طب بس هو
كان الطريق اللي حط لنا هي المسلسل انه
حياه المليونير كلهم كل اللي موجودين في
المسلسل هم مليونيريه المفروض
السؤال
اي احد عنده سته اصفار في حسابك هو
مليونير لا يعني اكيد كلنا عندنا ست اصفار
بس همم ما نعتبر مقارنه بالناس كثير اغنى
منه بمليون مره وبامرحل بس كمان الغني ما
راح يجي يقول عن نفسه اوكي
همم
نعمه رب العالمين ولكن ما حيطلع اي مشهد
اقول انا غنيه انا عندي انا املك
اكثر مني
وانا اقول الحمد لله
كانت مثلا
انت الوالده من البحرين بطياره خاصه هل
هذا شيء انت دائما بتسويه لانه برضو بعد
النصح يقولوا واو واحنا زي ما بنركب
السياره هي راحت اخذت السياره دائما لما
تحصل لي الفرصه يعني لما كنت اروح على
مهرجان جونه نعم اروح طائره خاصه في اتفاق
بيني وبين شركه جتكس انه يكون في جانب
ترويجي وهذا طبيعي ما راح اخبيه وايضا في
مصلحه يعني انا ما اسوي دعايه يعني انا ما
رح اخذها نقدا انا حاخذها مقابل رحلات
رحلات اوكي بالنسبه لي فرصه حتى الموجود
عندي في رحله اني انا اروح اجيب امي وكان
على فكره عيد الام انا عملتها مش رايحه
ولا جايباتها بس كده ايوه اوكي طب هل انتم
اصحاب فعلا في الحقيقه اللي موجودين في
المسلسل لا طبعا انا اتعرف عليهم من خلال
همم
ونقله على دبي جديده فقلت لها ذكرتيني اول
ما نقلت بس اهم شيء اهلك قراب منك يقدروا
يزوروكي هنا جاءت الصدف انه اخذنا محو
الحديث انه قالت لي علاقتي مقطوعه بامي
هنا حتى الكروم والشركه الانتاج التفاجه
وما كان يعرف عن هذه النقطه فهذه حقيقيه
واقعيه 100% وفعلا من واقع رغبه بداخل
حبيت اني اساعدها لانه انا بالنسبه لي امي
جنتي وناري ما استغني عنها في حياتي
من اولادك يعني همم الله لا يحرم احد يعني
همم من احد يحبه بس اذا كمان بدي ارجع
اسالك على كمان اللاين حقك في المسلسل او
دورك او كيف بنقول حياتك في المسلسل يعني
بعد الناس كمان قالوا انه ظهور اخوك معك
مازن قالوا انه حرام مازن انك انت قلت انه
مازن ما بيشتغل وانه انت
بتشرفتي
بشتغل يا جماعه
اول يوم دوام ههه الحمد لله رب العالمين
مبروك الله يبارك فيك لا بس هذا الواقع
وحال واقع حال شباب وشابات كثر تخرجوا ومو
ملاقين وظيفه ويعانوا لانه مش محصلين
وظيفه ااه بس هذا الواقع ليش اخبيه ليش
اقول لا والله اخوي ما شاء الله مدير شركه
هو متخرج لا الولد صار له ثلاث سنوات يدور
على وظيفه لانه اخو لوجين عمران الناس
متوقعين اكيد طبيعي
يعني البعض جاب مشهد لما همم جايبه ياخذ
200,000 اكيد اقدر ادفع بس انا ابغى يحس
بقيمه الشيء ساره اللي ياخذ الشيء تقولي
جمل زي كده مثلا لانه في ناس هيقولوا انه
كيف تتفشخر علينا
بس انا ماني من هذا النوع عندي انا حسابي
معها انتظر احد يعطيني فرصه يعني في اليوم
ارخص شيء واسهل شيء اي احد يقدر والله
شغاله
مسكها كانت عندي بالبيت الاسبوع الماضي
كان ممكن ما صورت همم دخلت غرفه للدرسين
قالت لي ممكن انادي زوجي يشوف غرفتك كانت
ان هي عمري ما شفتك صورتها قلت لها هذه
الغرفه مسويه مش للناس انا مستمتعه فيها
مش عشان الناس يستمتعوا فيها بس ما عندي
مانع تطلع اذا كان محتاج ظهور اذا رجعنا
بالوقت هل بتشاركي في المسلسل الثاني او
ندمانه
لاول مره على تويتر انا اشوف لجين
للناس
انت عمرك
دائما مجامله من الدرجه الاولى بس اذا ما
عندي كلمه كويسه اقدمها ما احب انت لتوتي
انا ضيفه
وانت صورتك اول صوره في البوستستر صحيح
يمكن لانه مقارنه اللي باقي الشخصيات قد
اكون انا الاقدام او الاكبر او الاشهر
ولكن انا بالنسبه لي صحيح ضيفه شوفي
مشاهدي ايوه انا لاني
المناسبه شكرا ههه
طيب مو مشكله على عدد السنوات التي مشكله
مع احد لا لا دخلت في اشكاليه دراما خلاف
حتى اللي يجرحني حتى اللي يطعني اعطي ظهري
عمري ما دخلت في خلاف ولا عندي نيه ادخل
في خلاف ما احد مش انا مش شخصيتي اللي
تواجه وتتخان وتعلي صوتها هل في جزء ثاني
هيكون المفروض مبدئيا وحسب ما سمعته قالت
العصفور راح يكون في سعودي برلينغ اه
احبكم في سعودي
بلينك اتوقع اذا هياخدوا ساودي بلينج لي
ساكن بالسعوديه طبعا فكل بلد اتوقع هيكون
فيه اكثر منجن حسب ما سمعت بس ما اعرف مدى
مصداقيه الخبر اوكي سؤال كلنا في عيد
ميلادك قلت فجاه انه اه تحيه لزوجي وكذا
ايوه صار كل احد يبعث يقول زوجها من زوجها
فين زوجها
وكيف شكله ايش اسمه
لا نجاوب بعد الهواء حبيبتي ههه
ما انت حابه تشاركي الناس شيء لانه الناس
فجاه تفاجات انه ابدا لجين انا احترم
خصوصيه زوجي بنتي ابني اذا ماعن هو راغب
انهم يظهرون فانا احترم خصوصيتهم هذا امي
بتطلع ابوي
اختي اسيل بس اختي الصغيره مثلا ما عندها
نيه
احترم خصوصياتهم كل واحد عنده شخصيه وكل
اللي قرر مش انا اقرر بالنيابه عنه طيب
بالتوفيق في الزواج شكرا
قلب من عندي في رسائل حب مشاهدينا كانت
معنا الاعلاميه السعوديه لجين عمران شكرا
لك